Get up and running with
your first Angular 2.0
application and new tools
to speed up your workflow.
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is "LazyWeb."
Get an early look at Angular
2.0 in this short tutorial.
Alex Eagle from the
Angular team demonstrates
how to build a to
do list, combining
the latest from Angular with
Firebase, a backend service
for storing real-time data.
The video also
highlights working
with TypeScript and Microsoft's
new Visual Studio Code editor.
Addy and Matt show off some
of their fancy Sublime tricks
in the new "Totally
Tooling Tip" series.
Episode one covers linters
like JSHint and JSCS for code
style, managing
colors in your app
with Code Highlighter and Color
Picker, and autocomplete tools
for filenames and CSS prefixes.
You can catch "Totally
Tooling Tips" every other week
on the Google Developers
YouTube channel.
Mark Marron and James
Mickens from Microsoft
demonstrate a new feature
in the F12 developer tools
that add the abilities to step
backwards through your program.
Debugger uses an efficient
snapshotting technique
of the JavaScript runtime
to keep your overhead
down so that way it can run as
you work without significantly
impacting performance.
Leave yourself a
note with this voice
recorder for the mobile web.
Paul Lewis details the process
of building a material design
voice recorder using features
like Recorder.js for waveforms
and Babelify for ES6.
The post takes an honest
look at issues still faced
by the web when it comes
to building applications.
If you want to check
out the source,
it's available now on GitHub.
"DevTips Daily" highlights
a new filmstrip view
which display snapshots of
your site as it was loading.
Based on a similar
feature from WebPagetest,
the tool helps
developers determine
when their site is first
usable and cut down
on render blocking assets.
To try the feature
yourself, you'll
need to download a
copy of Chrome Canary.
Jake and Paul return for
Season 2 of "HTTP 203."
Season 2 begins with
a brief discussion
of Jake's impending demise.
Paul grows a beard.
And somewhere in
the middle, they
rehash the age old debate
of web versus native.
If you have a few
minutes to kill
or just want to feel
better about your suntan,
tune in to this season of "HTTP
203" on the Google Developers
YouTube channel.
That's it for this week, folks.
Take a deep breath, enjoy
the visuals, and to all
you LazyWebbers
Out there, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]